[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي ليال اختيار السهلوها بابرس
العناوين
[تصفيق]
الان محابيس الكره
رونالدو رونالدو
بقياده رونالدو نجوم الهلال والنصر ضد
باريس سان جيرمان بقياده ميسي والشوط
الاول ينتهي بالتعادل
على بعد نصف خطوه الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
يقترب من القوائم الاوروبيه للارهاب
وطهران تصفها بحاله حرب
[موسيقى]
سلبيه لنداءات سنسكي الاسلحه الغربيه هالو
على اكياس دبابات ومدافع
وانظمه صاروخيه
بعد وصولها الى سقف الدين الخزانه
الامريكيه تعلن اللجوء لاستخدام اجراءات
استثنائيه
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من الرياض والمباراه
الوديه التي تجرى تجري الان وتجمع نجوم
فريق حي النصر والهلال من السعوديه مع
باريس سان جيرمان فرنسي وذلك في اطار موسم
الرياض وتقام المباراه على استاد الملك
فهد الدولي وتشير نتيجه الشوط الاول الى
تعادل الفريقين بهدفين لهدفين المباراه هي
الاولى كريستيانو رونالدو منذ انتقاله الى
النصر كما انها تجمع بغريمه على الصعيد
الفردي ليونيل ميسي نجم باريس سان جيرمان
المدرب الارجنتيني جايادو الاشراف على
فريق نجوم الهلال والنصر
اليوم يصل الكره ليو
الان محابس الكره امامنا بس صاروخي مديره
رونالدو رونالدو
اذا مشاهدينا هذه لقطات مباشره الان من
ستاد الملك فهد الدولي حيث تجري هناك
مباراه الوديه بين كل من فريق باريس سان
جيرمان بقياده ميسي والنصر والهلال بقياده
رونالدو طبعا للتذكير بان اخر مباراه جمعت
الغريمين كانت عامه 2020 بدوري ابطال
اوروبا مشاهدينا كما نتذكر يومها وطبعا هي
المباراه الاولى لرونالدو منذ انتقاله الى
فريق النصر السعودي ويقود اليوم هذه
المباراه اذا اليوم هذه المباراه تجمع بين
اكبر نجمين في تاريخ كره القدم
ولاول مره يعني يلعب النجمين خارج الاراضي
الاوروبيه هذه يعني نقطه مهمه جدا انما
يلعبان على ارض الرياض على
على ارض عاصمه الرياضه الرياض في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انتقل الى الرياض وزميل
نايف الثقيل مراسل العربيه نايف يعني
عندما نتحدث عن مباراه تجمع الغريمين
التاريخين
باكبر نجمين بتاريخ كره القدم اليوم يعني
على الساحه بهذا الاستاذ كيف هي الصوره من
هناك بالفاصل بين الشوطين الاول والثاني
فاصل بين الشوطين بعد ان عشنا يعني شوط
جميل جدا لا يعكس طبعا ان المباراه وديه
احتفاليه كان المستوى الفني عالي جدا كان
هناك تنافس على مستوى الفريقين وتفاعل
جماهي همم كبير همم الحضور طبعا همم
المدرجات ممتلئه الجماهير المحتفيه
ومحتفله كما ذكرت فعلا يعني ان يلتقي
كريستيانو رونالدو همم ميسي وجها لوجه
وبعد ان يعني الجميع فقد الامن يلتقي همم
مجددا همم الرياض وهمم استاد الملك فهد
يشهد هذه الامه تخيلي انه ما زال حتى الان
يعني هناك جماهير هيصه حتى على الحضور همم
الجزء الثاني من همم المباراه همم
ويحاولون باللحاء للحضور المباريات كمان
بتشاهدين يعني هناك تجمع بعض الجماهير
التي لم تتمكن همم من الدخول ايضا هناك
يعني مئات
الجمعيه يعني وقد تكون بالالاف في المنطقه
الخارجيه للملعب ولكن يعني التنظيم العالي
الذي تم تطبيقه اليوم في المباراه ووضع
اكثر من نقطه نقطه فرز ونقطه همم نقطه
امنيه للتنظيم منعت همم تكدس الجماهير همم
داخل المناطق المحيطه
الملعب همم كان هناك دخول بسلاسه جدا سهله
همم
للجماهير وهمم ويعني لاحظنا انه يعني همم
التوافق او فتح البوابات يعني في وقت مبكر
سهم في عدم التكدس عدم همم انتظام
الجماهير في اوقات طويله في ناس همم نقاط
الفيز وقراءه
على التذاكر تحدثنا خلال هذا النهار عن
اكثر من مليوني بطاقه بقيت يعني يستان باي
لم يست الدخول الى ارض الملعب الى اي مدى
كان هناك اقبال كثيف على هذه المباراه
بالفعل هناك اقبال كثيف على على التذاكر
هناك همم كانت يعني راويه مؤشر للجهات
المنظمه همم الاقبال 2 مليون في قائمه
الانتظار كانت مؤشر كبير
للجهات المناظمه لذلك تداوكه الامر وهناك
يعني شاشات متعدده في مدينه الرياض تنقل
احداث هذه المباراه بخلاف الاماكن العامه
الاخرى همم بالفعل يعني الاقبال كان كبير
وانا لا حط يعني تواجد جماهير من من دول
مختلفه دول اجنبيه وايضا الاغلبيه كانت
لدول الخليج ودول العربيه وكان هناك
عائلات حضرات همم من الاردن ومن الكويت
ومن البحرين وايضا بعض الجماهير انه
هذا الملعب احتضن مناسبات مهمه جدا هذا
الاسبوع بالامس كان السوبر الايطالي وقبل
كان السوبر الاسباني لذلك كانت غزلان
مواضيحه للمشجع الرياضي وحضرت الجماهير
اكسب اا من مباراه واكثر من مناسبه في
غضون اربعه او خمسه ايام هناك بالامس
كانوا اا جماهير ايطاليا حضرت السوبر
واستمرت او بقت في الرياض لحضور المباراه
اليوم التاريخيه همم نايف يعني سنبقى
نتابع معك طبعا مجريات الشوط الثاني اذا
امكن ان ناخذ يعني بعض الاراء من الجماهير
الذين ما زالوا يتوافدون الى الملعب الان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
مانشستر يونايتد نسخه الاولى والى الان
شوف جانا النصر ترك تشجيع الهلال المتعصب
والهلالي شجع رونالدو كل من رجعت رونالدو
والنصر السعودي
هلالي اليوم تشوف كريستيانو وميسي
[موسيقى]
النصر هو الهلال
موفق يا حبيبي
ولكن يعني اجواء جميله وخياليه طبعا اجواء
حماسيه ضمن هذه المباراه التي تاتي ضمن
فعاليات الرياض موسم
ثقيل مراسل العربيه على هذه الرساله
[موسيقى]
وفي العراق
اجره المباراه النهائيه او تجرى الان
المباراه النهائيه بين المنتخبين العراقي
والعماني ضمن بطوله كاس الخليج الخامس
والعشرين التي تقام في البصره حاليا هذا
ولا جاء المنتخبان للاشواط الاضافيه بعد
تعادلهما بهدف لهدف وسبق المباراه احدث
مؤسفه بعد تدافع الجماهير التي احتشد فيها
الالاف منهم لدخول الى الملعب
النخله في البصره ما اذى لوفاه مشجع
واصابه 60 اخرين
حمود
[موسيقى]
صوت البرلمان الاوروبي في اجتماعه اليوم
لصالح قرار يدعو الى تصنيف الحارس الثوري
منظمه ارهابيه كما صوت ايضا لادراج المرشد
عليقه والرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي اضافه الى
المدعي العام الايراني محمد منتظر على
قوائم العقبات البرلمان الاوروبي طلب
باحاله ملف انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في
ايران الى مجلس الامن وادانا بشده اعمال
التعذيب والعنف وانتزاع الاعترافات بالقوه
في سجود الايرانيه بدورها وصفت صحف
ايرانيه مواليه ومقربه من النظام الخطوه
الاوروبيه باعلان حرب على طهران محذره من
عواقبه وخيمه
اكد دبلوماسيان بالاتحاد الاوروبي ان
فرنسا وهولندا تقدان دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
التي تؤيد ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه ونقلت
رويترز عن المصدرين الدبلوماسيين ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يتجه لاضافه
37 كيانا جديدا لقائمه العقوبات المفروض
على ايران الاثنين المقبل
اذا بتوقيع اوروبي هذه المره الحرس الثوري
الايراني على بعد نصف خطوه من ان يصنف
تنظيما ارهابيا بعد مصادقه البرلمان
الاوروبي على مشروع القرار بانتظار
التصويت لاحقا ليس هذا فحست اذ ان القرار
الاوروبي دعى علانيه الى ادراج راس النظام
في ايران المتمثل ابراهيم رئيسي والمرشد
الاعلى علي الخامنئي في قائمه العقوبات
وكما كان متوقعا قرار دفع بطهران الى
الجنون وبالتالي توعدت بان هذه الخطوه
ستؤثر على الامن والاستقرار الاقليمي
والسلام العالم المهدده البرلمان الاوروبي
من عواقبه وخيمه وزير الخارجيه الايراني
دانا بشده القرار وحذر من ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيطلق النار على قدميه بادراج
الحرس الثوري على قوائم المنظمات
الارهابيه وعلى وقع هذه التحذيرات حضر
خبراء بشان تعليم ان الرد الايراني على
تصنيف الحارس الثوري في قوائم الارهاب
الاوروبيه سيكون عبر تحريك من الشياكه في
كل من العراق وسوريا ولبنان ومحاوله ضرب
المصالح الغربيه هناك هناك مشروع قرار فرض
عقوبات على الحارسه ثوريه الايراني يشمل
وضع كل المؤسسات التابعه لهم مثل قوات
البسيج وفيق القدس على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه
طبعا القمع الحاد للمتظاهرين في ايران
وتنفيذ العديد من عمليات الاعدام بين
المحتاجين ساهم ايضا برفع صوت البرلمان
الاوروبي للمطالبه بادراج الحرس الثوري في
قائمه الارهاب الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه انا رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بحثا مع مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي
الايراني وجهود التي يبذلها الرئيس
كما بحث جهود السلام
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من ليفربول ديفيد لو
المحاضر في الشؤون الامنيه وضابط سابق في
مكافحه الارهاب استاذ اييه ديفيد عندما
نتحدث عن ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على
قائمه الارهاب نعني ادراج الكيان السياسي
والعسكري للنظام الذي يراسه خامنئي بنفسه
ماذا يعني ذلك على يعني انشطه ايران
بالمنطقه والعالم
بريلي
مثيره جدا من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
الولايات المتحده سبق وان ادرجت وضمن
المنظمات الارهابيه اقصد الحرس الثوري
الايراني ولكن هذه الخطوات
في ايران والحرسه
والنقل البحري القرار اعتقد بانه سياسيه
اكثر ما هو ماشي ولا ارى اي تهديد همم
وليس للتحدث اوروبي يمثلها الحرس الثوري
ااا طبعا الحرق من المعروف ان الحرس
الثوري يسيطر على جزء كبير جدا من الانشطه
الاقتصاديه بعد الانشطه العسكريه لايران
في الخارج ومعظم الانشطه الاقتصاديه
والماليه تمر عبره ادراج اليوم على قائمه
الارهاب كيف تضر بالمصالح الاقتصاديه
للحرس
مثلا
بخصوص زياده العقوبات عليه ايران واشهد ان
هذه العقوبات منذ سنوات طويله
خاصه
عقبات اضافيه بالتاكيد ستؤثر على ايران
وعلى الحكومه اقتصاديه
ولكنها في نفس الوقت ستؤثر على المواطنين
الايرانيين والامر يعتمد على ان يعمل
العقوبات وعلى ماذا ستنطبق ولكنها بلا شك
ستعوق قدرات ايران والحرسه
تم تفعيلها
ولديهم تواجد في لبنان
وبلاشياء كامله في دول المنطقه
همم هذه القدرات اعتمد على الحكومه
الايرانيه هو اي نوع من الاموال التي
لديهم وكيف
يستخدمونه ولكنها خوفي هو معاناه الشعب
الايراني اكثر يعني
ممكن ان تؤثر على انشطه العسكريه اتحدث
انا عن المعدات بما ان فتمنع العديد من
الدول من اعضاء اي شيء او ماده باي شيء
بالطرق يعني الملتويه او المباشره باختصار
لو سمحت
نعم هؤلاء الذين يزودونا الا استحاله
المعداته لايران بالتاكيد العقوبات
ستدخل وتمنع هذه الشركات خارج ايران والتي
قد ايه
للشركات الاوروبيه وحتى من امريكا
والاخرى في المنطقه
الاشاره الى ذلك اقتصاديا يؤثر على قدرتي
همم الحرس الثوري على توسيعه وعدم قدرته
الحصول على المواد بسهوله وحتى الحصول على
الاسلحه التي يستخدمها الحرس الثوري
ااا استاذ ديفيد له محاضره في الشؤون
الامنيه وضابط سابق في مكافحه الارهاب على
هذه المدن
تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
الصين تعلن انخفاض اصابات كورونا في
البلاد بمقدار النصف تقريبا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الملف الاوكراني
وتطورات الحرب هناك افاده مراسل العربيه
بهجوم القوات الاوكرانيه على منطقه اثباتو
وطريق السريع بين حركات
الشماليه والتي يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
والذي بدوره رد على هذا الهجوم بتكثيف
القصف بالمدفعيه والصواريخ كما خلال
الاربع عشرين ساعه الماضيه استهدف الجيش
الاوكراني مدينه دنياسك وضواحيها ب 300
صاروخ وقذيفه مدفعيه ادت الى اصابه شخص
والحق اضرار في الابنيه السكنيه ومرافق
تحتيه
اذا تطورات متصاعده على جبهات الشرق
الاكرانيه كشفت روسيا هجماتها فيها
القوات الاوكرانيه من مدينه
بيلو جروبكا
العسكريه مستمره فيها وتهدف الهجمات
الروسيه لتوسيع الطوق حول الجيش في مدن
شمال
الناحيه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
حتى الرئيس الروسي او الرئيس الاوكراني
اوكرانيا علاء
برنس برنس
و طائرات بدون طيار بالاضافه الى التدريب
ستتبر اوكرانيا
و سترسل استونيا معدات عسكريه الى
اوكرانيا تبلغ قيمتها نحو 122 مليون دولار
كما تعاهدت لتوانيا بتقديم 125 مليون يورو
كمساعده عسكريه لاوكرانيا
ادخلت روسيا مؤخرا دبابات تيت 90 الى ارض
المعركه في جمباز فما هي مواصفات هذه
الدبابه
[موسيقى]
تزامنا مع القذف الاوكراني على مدينه
دانيت وضواحيها توجهنا الى بلده
الكسندراكا التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
شمال غربي المقاطعه ما زالت البلده تتعرض
لقصف عنيف وبقي فيها قليل من السكان
قريه الكسندرا المتاخمه لمدينه مارينكا
حيث المعارك الساخنه المستمره حيث يستمر
الجيش الروسي بمواصله اعماله العسكريه رغم
سقوط القذائف والصواريخ على مناطق
المدنيين تتيانا تعاني من اعاقه بساقها
حدثتنا عن معاناتها بعد تعرض بيتها القصف
والصغير بزوجها
سقطت في منزلي فتصلت بوالدي مباشره
الى انعدام الغاز ذلك ما جعل مدفاه الحطب
صانعه الدفء والطعام في هذا المكان
في العصر الحجري وانا احضر الطعام من لا
شيء على الحطب هذه الاواني
وي صاروخ
كمان
ما كان اقامه الجيش الروسي ونقطه انطلاقه
لمواجهه الجيش الاوكراني في مدينه مارينكا
المتاخمه لها ذلك ما يجعلها دائما في مرمى
نيران القوات الاوكرانيه دخلنا الى احدى
السكنات العسكريه لنسمع من الجنود عن
احوال المعارك في هذه المنطقه همم
والحمد لله ليس لدينا قتل حتى الان
من هذا المكان وعلى بعد عشرات الامطار ما
زالت الاله العسكريه الروسيه تقصف
بالمدافع وراجمات الصواريخ مواقع الجيش
الاوكرانيه التي مازال لا تتمركز في اخر
المدينه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
اواخر مارينكا مقاطعه دانيت
فرو من الخطوط الاماميه في منطقه يارسلاف
الروسيه بعد قصف الاوكرانيه عنيف رساله
مصوره الى رئيس بلادهم فلاديمير بوتين
نشاتها مجله نيوز
التجمع اكثر من 30 جنديا روسيا ملثمين
يضحون فيه انهم لم يفروا من ساحه المعركه
انما تم تضليلهم من قبل قائدهم الذي طلب
منهم التراجع عن المهمه الجنود الروس
اكدوا ان قائد السريه امرهم بالانسحاب من
المواقع بعد قصفهم بالدبابات والمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه واوضحوا ان القياده لم تقدم
لهم اي غطاء او دعم وانهم لا يملكون الا
بنادق هجوميه بعدما تضررت جميع الاسلحه
الاخرى وتم ارسال الفيديو طبعا الى امهات
وزوجات وجنود لدشرها على اوسع نطاق
لتبريتهم من تهمه الفراق
روسيا ان تجد حلا لهذه المساله قائدنا
امرنا بالتراجع عن المهمه والانسحاب بعد
ان واجهنا قصفا عنيفا كما انه لم يقدم لنا
اي غطاء او دعم لم نكن نملك الى البنادق
الهجوميه بعد ان تضررت جميع الاسلحه
الاخرى الان يريدون ان يتهموننا بالفرار
وقائدنا قال انه لم يعطينا الامر القائد
لم يهتم لامرنا ومنذ البدايه قيل لنا اننا
في الخطوط الدفاعيه
القلم تدرس اداره الرئيس الامريكي تقديم
المزيد من المساعده لاوكرانيا وفقا ما
كشفته طبعا صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
التي اكدت ان واشنطن بدات تلين بعد ما رفض
التزويد اكياس بالاسلحه التي تحتاجها
لاستهداف شبه الجزيره الاوكرانيه التي
ضمتها روسيا عام 2014
وتستخدمها موسكو اليوم
لشان ضربات مدمره على اوكرانيا المسؤولون
الامريكيون اق فعل بانكياف بحاجه الى قوه
ضاربه لتحرير الجزيره رغم خطوره الخطوه
التي تعتبر تصعيدا كبيرا بوجه روسيا طبعا
بحسب الصحيفه الاعتدال بالموقف الامريكي
مشاهدينا بعد التشدد تجاه القرب يعود الى
ان واشنطن تعتبر ان تحديد موسكو بنزع
القرب منها سيعزز موقف كافي اي مفاوضات
مستقبليه بعد ما تضائلت المحاوف من ان
ينتقم الكريم لاستخدام سلاح نووي تكتيكي
وفقا للصحيفه
[موسيقى]
من ذوي المدافع هذا الى نيران التحذير
والوعيد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي حظر الغرب من مساعد تسليح اوكرانيا
باسلحه ثقيله وانظمه هجوميه
متواعدا بان خساره قوه النوويه مثل روسيا
في حرب تقليديه ستؤدي الى اندلاع حرب
النوويه تحذير عززه الكرملين واكد
بالاضافه ان تحذيرات من الحرب النوويه
تتوافق تماما مع العقيده النوويه الروسيه
يتزمن ذلك مع تحولات جذريه
رساله لقياف لمساعدتها في ضرب شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وفقا
يورك تايمز الصحيفه اضافت انه بعد اشهر من
المناقشات مع ودينا الاوكرانيين بدات
ادارته بيض اخيرا لاعتراف بانك قد تحتاج
الى القوه لضرب هذا الملاذ الروسيه حتى لو
كانت هذه الخطوه ستزيد من خطر التصعيد
القرم الواقعه بين البحر الاسود وبحر اذوب
موطن لعشرات الالاف من الجنود الروس روسيا
تعتمد الى حد كبير على قواعدها العسكريه
في شبه جزيره القرم في شن هجمات مكانتها
من الاستيلاء على الاراضي جنوبيه اوكرانيا
العام الماضي
الولايات المتحده اصرت ولسنوات على ان
القرم لا تزال جزءا من اوكرانيا
اعطونا اسلحتكم سنستعيد ارضنا
جزيره القرم تعود لواجهه الاحداث من جديد
مسار اخر تدخله الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
مع سعي كل طرف للسيطره على كامل اراضي شبه
جزيره القرم
هكذا رد البيت الابيض على تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه روسيه الذي قارن رد الغرب على
الحرب في اوكرانيا مع تكتكات الزعيم
النسيم البيت الابيض وصف كلام لافروف
بالادعاءات السخيفه والمضحكه وانها روايات
خاطئه منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كوريا شدد
ان روسيا هي التي بدات الحرب وانك لا تشكل
اي تهديد
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من موسكو يفجيني
سدراف استاذ يفجيني يعني اليوم هناك وجهه
نظر غربيه وتحديدا في واشنطن بان التهديد
بالتصعيد الروسي وبالانتقام اصبح وكانه
يعني يعتبر خداع من قبل بوتن ولا يطبق
فعليا على الارض امام يعني منذ دخول الحرب
هذا الشهر نقطه تحول جذريه ممكن ان ينحرف
بها مسار الحرب على الارض كيف سترد موسكو
على كل الخطوات الغربيه الجديده
تحيه لك وليس هذا المشاهدين روسيا طبعا
ستردوا على
التطورات الاخيره المتمثله في نوايا دول
الغربيه في تقديم مزيد من الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا الاسلحه التي لم يعني تقدمها
الدول الغربيه اليكيه سابقا روسيا سوف ترد
على ذلك طبعا
بخطوه ربما تتناسب مع حجم الخطر الذي يمكن
ان يخيم على روسيا ولكن في نفس الوقت نرى
ان مثل هذا
التصعيد الذي لم يتعدى حتى الان على الاقل
القدر الدبلوماسيه او الاثر الكلاميه
والتصريحات هو بتبيه الحال همم ربما ياتي
في اطار او في سياق توقعات تسود كلا من
موسكو وكافو ودول الغربيه لاسيه مع
الولايات المتحده باح معليشني طرفين
الروسي ولوكراني هجوما وهجوم المضاده في
مع التهاب فصل الشتاء وربما حلول فصل
الربيع ولشك ان التصريحات التي يتم
الادلاء بها اليوم من الطرفين من روسيا من
اوكرانيا وكذلك من الطرف الثالث الطرف
الغربي عموما يدل على ان الهدف منها ربما
استعراض قدره كل طرف على همم اتخاذ خطواته
من شانها ان تضمن الموقف القوي في
المفاوضات القادمه اليوم يعني التلميح او
او الدعوه المباشره الى ضرب القرد يعني
اعاده الحرب واخذه الى المربع الاول القرم
التي يعني تعتبر نقطه استراتيجيه لموسكه
والاكتي كانت محط خلاف بين القوى العالميه
تاريخيا اليوم اذا في حال اقدمت اكياس على
ضربه باسلحه غربيه هذا الارباك لموسكو كيف
سترد عليه
ليس هناك اي اساس للتاكيد على النقيب
بالفعل تستطيع ان تضرب شبه جزيره القرم
لاستعاداتها كما يزعمون لان القرم اولا
عباره لا شيما مناسبه البحري اييي عباره
عن حصن مليئه هناك غواصات وهناك سفن حربيه
وهناك خطوط دفاعيه وقدرات قتاليه ضخمه
ولذلك يجب على كيف لكي تحقق هذه المهمه
وهي تبدو برايي الان مستحيل تماما ان تزيد
من قدراتها العسكريا ليس بمرتين او ثلاث
مرات مثلا وانما عشرات المرات لكي تحقق
هذه المهمه ووضح تماما ان مثل هذه النوايا
الصادره عن كيف غير حقيقيه وغير واقعيه في
الوقت الحاضر وبالتالي لا اساس لها ربما
من الصحه
مشاكل الارباك لموسكو وطبعا يعني هذا
المراد من هذا الموضوع همم استاذ
يفقينيس دروف
تفضل باختصار
هو كنت اريد ان اقول ان روسيا بتربيه
الحال سترد كما ردت على محاوله استهداف
جسر القرم منذ عده اشهر بنفس القوه وربما
بقوه تزيد بكثير اما كانت عليه انا ذات
الكلام
كيف تطالب واشنطن والغرب حسب موقفهم من
ارسال الدبابات وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
الغربيه باسرع وقت لانه اوكرانيا لا تملك
الوقت ولكن على ارض الواقع هل يؤدي منح
الغرب دبابات لاوكرانيا لانتصارها ام
يوقعها في الفخ الذي سقطت به روسيا قبلها
صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه اوضحت في تقرير
لها ان توفير دبابات القتال الرئيسيه
المصممه من النيته يمثل بعض التحديات
الرئيسيه لان دبابات ليوبار تو الالمانيه
التي تزن حوالي 69 طنا
البريطانيه التي تزن حوالي 72 وطنا اثقل
بمقدار 20 طنا من دبابات القتال الرئيسيه
المصممه من الاتحاد السوفيتي والتي تشغلها
اوكرانيا حاليا والبنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا لا تسمح لمثل
المركبات الثقيله السفر على طولها في حين
ان مركباتها الهندسيه وعربه الاصلاح مخصصه
لدعم التصاميم السوفياتيه حصرا تحدي اخر
توجهك لان الدبابات المصممه من النيته
تحتاج الى تدريبات مكثفه لاستخدامها في
ساحه المعركه اما من ناحيه التكتيك الحربي
فقد توقع الدبابات النيته اوكرانيا بالفخ
عينه الذي وقعت فيه موسكو في بدايه الحرب
لانه قد يشجعها على تنفيذ هجوم مكشوف وقد
تصبح طوابير الدبابات الغربيه الصنع في يد
الاوكرانيين هدفا لاصول المروحيات
والطائرات النفاثه الروسيه مثل طائرات
سخوي 25 مثل ما كانت الدبابات الروسيه
خلاله هجوم اكياس في الربيع هدفا لهجمات
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه المحموله على الكتف
والطائره المسيره من طراز برقدار التركي
تركيا
[موسيقى]
اعلن المتحدث باسمي وصارات الدفاع السويدي
يعني وزير الدفاع للسفر الى انقره بدعوه
من نظيره الترك
في الوقت الذي تعمل فيه السويد الى
الانضمام
اعلنتا السلطات في صربيا اجرائها عمليات
بحث طارئه عن شخصين مفقودين سحبهما سيل
الانبياء بعد سقوط امطار وصلت الى المستوى
الغزير في منطقه البلقان هذا الاسبوع ما
ادى الى ارتفاع منسوب الانهار الى مرحله
خطيره غرقت على اثرها مناطق سكانيه في
صربيا والبوسنه والجبل الاسود
[موسيقى]
اعلنت مديره قسم الاستجابه الطبيه للطوارئ
في لجنه الصحه وطنيه الصينيه انخفاض نسبه
الاصابات بكرونا بمعدل وصل الى
44.3% مقارنه بفتره الذره
العلاج
اليوميه ثلاث مقاطعه تجاوزت ذروه زيارات
عياده الحمى وقسم الطوارئ والاعراض الحاده
وصل عدد مرضى كوفي الذروته في الخامس من
يناير ثم استمر في الانخفاض بنسبه بلغت 44
فاصله ثلاثه بالمئه مقارنه بفتره الذروه
اعداد المحتاجين على خطه التقاعد في فرنسا
تجاوزت المليون شخص
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في فرنسا اعلن مصدر في
الشرطه الفرنسيه ان عدد المتظاهرين في
عموم البلاد تجاوز المليون شخص هذا
واستخدمت شرطه باريس الغاز المسير للدموع
باتجاه المحتاجين على خطط الحكومه لرفع سن
التقاعد عامين الى اربعه وستين عاما
وتمثل الاضرابات والاحتجاجات اختبار جديده
للرئيس ماكرون الذي يقول ان خطته لاصلاح
نظام التقاعد ضروريه لضمان عدم الافلاس
واعلن قاده النقابات عن اضرابات واحتجاجات
مستمره حتى تتراجع الحكومه عن قراراتها
[موسيقى]
من جهتي تعهد الرئيس الفرنسيه مانويل
ماكرون بالمضيق قدما في اصلاح لا يحظى
بشعبيه في فرنسا لنظام معاشات التقاعد
مشيرا الى ان الحكومه الفرنسيه ستنفذ
الامر باحترام وبروح من الحوار والى جانب
الحزم والمسؤوليه فيما خرج مئات الالف من
الفرنسيين في باريس ومدن فرنسيه احتجاجا
على اصلاح نظام التقاعد
ينضم الينا من باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه حسين عندما نتحدث عن تظاهره
مليونيه تاريخيه لم تحصل منذ العام 95
ماذا يعني ذلك
هذا يعني النقمه الشعبيه الكبيره ما حصل
يذكرنا تماما بما ذكرته ليال التظاهرات
الحاشده خلال العام الاول من الولايه
الاولى لجاكشراك عندما كان الان جي بي
حينها رئيسا للوزراء وطرح مشروع قانون
لاصلاح نظام الضمان الاجتماعي ونظام
التقاعد ايضا ويذكرنا بالعام 2003 عندما
سارت تظاهرات كبيره ضد وزير العمل
فرانسوافيو الذي اصبح لاحقا رئيسا للوزراء
عندما كان وزيرا للعمل ايضا ترحها مشروعا
لاصلاح نظام التقاعد وكان عدد المتظاهرين
حينها قريبا سجل اليوم بالمناسبه وزاره
الداخليه اعلنت قبل قليل ان العدد النهائي
وزاره الداخليه لعدد العدد النهائي
للمتظاهرين عبر فرنسا بلغ مليون
و120,000 متطهر فيما تؤكد الكونفدراليه
العامه للعمل ان عدد المتظ فين عبر فرنسا
تجاوز المليونير هذا مؤشر على ان نقمه
الشعبيه كبيره وهناك موجات لاحقه من
التظاهرات والتحركات ستسجل يوم السبت
المقبل بدعوه من حركه فرنسا العصيه من
اقصى اليسار ستشارك في التحرك احزاب
اليسار الاخرى من الاشتراك الى الشيوع الى
حزب البيئه الاسبوع المقبل تنظم النقابات
ايضا تظاهرات جديده واحتجاجات وايضا
الاسبوع الاول من الشهر المقبل ستسجل
احتجاجات جديده تحركات اليوم لم تقتصر على
باريس انما شملت مدن كبرى من بينها
مارسيليا ونيس واليوم والليل وتلوث ومدن
منطقه الناردين وعدد الموقوفين الذين
اوقفتم الشرطه لم يتجاوز 38 شخصا مليونا
شخص اذا حسب النقابات نزلوا الى الشوارع
في باريس ولم يحصل اي لم يحصل اي حادث هذا
مرده الى انه خلافا لتظاهرات السترات
الصفر فانا الت الكرات التي تدعو اليها
النقابات هي تظاهرات تكون هناك خلالها
مجموعات نظاميه من النقابات تعنى بالتنسيق
مع الشرطه لمنع حصول اضطرابات وهذا ما حصل
اليوم لم تحصل اضطرابات تذكر وحيات رئيسه
الوزراء اليزابيث بورن مساء اليوم جهود
النقابات لضمان حصول تظاهرات في ظروف جيده
بينما اعترف وزير العمل بان التحرك كانت
واسعه النطاق لكنه ذكر ايضا بان الاصلاحات
تبقى ضروريه وسيكون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
عاديلا يقصد رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ليال بدلا من 62 حاليا نعم همم حسين الطوب
مراسل العربيه شكرا لك على هذه الرساله من
العاصمه حسين قنيبر عفوا من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده اعلنت الخزانه
الامريكيه البدء في استخدام اجراءات
استثنائيه بعد الوصول الى سقف الدين ومن
الممكن ان تساعد مثل هذه الاجراءات غير
العاديه في تقليل حجم ديون المستحقه الا
ان وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه حذرت من ان
الاجراءات لم تساعد الا لفتره محدوده على
الارجح ليست اكثر من سته اشهر بدوره قال
رئيس
انه لا ينبغي للحكومه ان تلعب بسقف الديون
وفي الوقت نفسه دعى رئيس اكبر بنك امريكيه
لعدم التشكيك في الجداره الائتمانيه
للحكومه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا فاز العراق ببطوله كاس
الخليج على عمان في المباراه النهائيه كما
نتابع بهذه الصور المباشره وهي تكون المره
الاولى بعد الفوز الاول عام 88 اذا العراق
تعود لساحه البطولات
الرياضيه وتحديدا كره القدم وطبعا هناك
العديد من الاسئله بعد هذه
البطوله ان كانت ستساهم هذه المباراه
باقناع الفيفا برفع حظر استضافه المباريات
في كل من بغداد
مبروك علينا هذه
العراق حصل على هذا اللقب عام 88 عمان حصل
على حصلت عليه عام 2017 اليوم لاول مره
منذ 79 تعاد هذه المباريات في بغداد
والعراق يتوج بطلا في كاس الخليج
بالبصره
اذا مشاهدينا مع فوز العراق نعود الى
واشنطن والى موضوع الديون الامريكيه
والزميل لحسين الطود حسين يعني هناك طبعا
وجهتي نظر اليوم بهذا الموضوع وهناك جزل
حول هذا التعديل التي قامت به الحكومه
الامريكيه ما هي الاجواء من هناك حول هذا
الموضوع
تحيه لك ليال هذه الاجراءات التي اعلنت
عنها وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه تاتي في وقت
يتزايد في الجدل بين البيت الابيض من جهه
والجمهوريين في مجلس النواب من جهه اخرى
البيت الابيض يجادل بان رفع سقف الدين غير
قابل للتفاوض فيما يقول الجمهوريون وعلى
راسهم طبعا رئيس مجلس النواب قبل نقارتي
بان رفع سقف اليدين يجب ان يشمل تخفيضات
في الانفاق الحكومي ودعي البيت الابيض الى
محادثات وهو امر يرفضها حتى الان البيت
الابيض كما اشرنا همم طبعا نقار في حتى
الان لم يفصل ما هي الانفاقات التي يريدها
ولكنه همم المح اكثر من مره سابقا بانه
يؤيد تخفيض الانفاق الدفاعي طبعا في هذه
الاثناء همم
الانذار الان متجهه نحو زعيم جمهوريين في
مجلس الشيوخ مش مقانا الذي قال اليوم بان
الولايات المتحده هو متاكد ان الولايات
المتحده لن تتخلف عن سداد ديونها وانه
متاكد بان المشرعين مجلس النواب والبيت
الابيض سيتوصلون الى اتفاقا يجنب الولايات
المتحده هذا التخلف عن الاسداد الديون نعم
اذا اذا حسين يعني استمعنا ايضا الى تصريح
رئيس مصر في جيبي مورجان الذي اعتبر ان
هذا الاجراء ما كان يجب ان يكون همم ما هي
وجهه النظر المصرفيه هناك بهذا الموضوع
ليال هناك تحضيرات من ان تتخلف الولايات
المتحده عن سدد الديون سيؤدي اولا همم الى
خضه في الاسواق الماليه تاخر في دفعه
رواتب الموظفين الفدلاليين وايضا نتاخر في
بالنسبه لصندوق الضمان الاجتماعي وبالنسبه
للمتقاعدين الان اذا اذا تم همم وقعت انه
همم تخلفت الولايات المتحده لاول مره في
تاريخها عن سدد هذه الديون سيكون انك ايضا
مشاكل اخرى سيكون هناك خسائر في الوظائف
نحو ثلاثه مليون وظيفه همم سيخسرها
الامريكيون بالاضافه ايضا الى تراجع في
همم صندوق همم الضمان بالنسبه للمتقاعدين
الامريكيه الذي يسمى هنا بالقوه اذا فقد
ذلك سيكون هناك ارتفاع في همم
مدفوعات بنسبه لرهون العقارات المنزليه
اذا هناك تخوف من ازمه ماليه حتى همم لو
همم اكد يعني اليوم بانه متاكد بانه لن
يكون هناك ازمه ماليه ولكن خبراء
الاقتصاديون من جهه الاخرى يتخوفون من هذه
الاجراءات ويتخوفون من اي من ان تسبب او
يسبب هذا الخلاف السياسي بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين همم بوقوع هذا التخلف لاول
مره وبالتالي همم توجه نحو ازمه اقتصاديه
كبيره همم تقول لها تداعيات اكبر تداعيات
كارثيه على الاقتصاد الامريكي الذي الان
بدا يتعافى من همم تداعيات ازمه كورونا
والحج الصحي اضافه الى طبعا الى الحرب
الروسيه في همم في اوكرانيا والغزل الروسي
الى اوكرانيا كله هذه همم
التداعيات يتخوف منها الاقتصاديون هنا
اتحدث عن الاقتصاديه الاساسيه والديهم همم
رؤى اخرى بالنسبه للجمهوريين يرون بان رفع
سقف الدائن هو هو رافع يجب ان يستغل لونها
لكي يحصل على مكاسب خاصه تتعلق بموضوع
الرفاق الحكومي يجب ان نذكر بان في
الولايات المتحده هناك مدرستان المدرسه
همم يعني يتراسها الجمهوريون تدعو الى عدم
التدخل الدوله في جميع ويشئون الحياه
الاجتماعيه ومدرسه اخرى همم يتراسها
الديمقراطيه وخاصه التقدميون من
الديمقراطيين الذين يرونون ان للدوله دور
مهم في احقاق العداله الاجتماعيه اذن هناك
خلاف في وجهات النظر بين مدرستين في
الولايات المتحده كلهم الان يحاول ان يسعى
لتحقيق اكبر عدد ممكن من المكاسب لجههته
شكرا لك حسين الطهور مراسل العربيه حدثنا
نعود مشاهدينا الى هذه اللقطات من مباراه
نجوم النصر والهلال بقياده كريستيانو
رونالدو ضد باريس سان جيرمان بقياده ميسي
والنتيجه تشير الان بالتقدم باريس سان
جيرمان خمسه اهداف مقابل ثلاثه لفريق
النصر والهلال بقياده طبعا رونالدو اذا
كما كنا قد ذكرنا مشاهدينا همم هذه
المباراه جمعت اكبر نجمين بتاريخ كره
القدم لاول مره خارج يعني الاراضي
الاوروبيه على ارض عربيه وتحديدا على ارض
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في الرياض ضمن
فعاليات الرياض هذه المباراه الوديه همم
يتواجه فيها كل من ميسي ورونالدو بقياده
الفريقين بعد ما كان قد توجهها لاخر مره
عام 2020 في دوري ابطال اوروبا
بشر
والافكار للقائد الملهم
سمو سيدي
ولي يلعب على تطورنا في العديد من
المجالات وقف سائله تنمويه هائله تعيش
المملكه ولا يسار الطريق امام كبير للكثير
من الاحلام التي ستتحقق لهذا الشعب يستحق
هذا الشعب الكثير الكره تصل مره اخرى
وتستحق هذه
الا الاهتمام اللي يشاهد من مولاي خادم
الحرمين واسم سيدي ولي العهد نستحق
يستحقون كل هذا الحب وكل هذا تقدير على ما
يلونا من اهتمام كبير
لشعبهم ولا ايضا مواطنين
المتواجدين على ارض المملكه الكره تصل مره
اخرى العوده بعد ذلك يوصل الميدان لن تكون
الاخيره سيكون خلف الكثير من المباريات
الكبيره والاحداث العالميه
في السابق
ماهر يونس ثاني اقدم اسير سياسي في العالم
يعانق الحريه بعد 40 عاما في سجون
الاسرائيليه افرج عن ماهر بعد الافراج عن
ابن عمه وصديقه في الاسر كريم يونس
ليجتمعان مره اخرى ولكن هذه المره خارج
السجون
عاما احتضنت والده الاسير الحاجه وداد
يونس البالغ من العمر
88 عاما نجلها اليوم لاول مره
شعوري لا لا يوصف بعيد 40 سنه ضميته لصدري
صحابي بيتجوز
ماهر وكريم يونس اولاد العم واصدقاء الصبا
بعد ان امضيات طفولته ما سويا
زملاء في السجن لاربعين عاما اليوم
يلتقيان وهما يتنفسان الحريه
هذا شعور لا يوصف وان كنا يعني لا يمكن
الوصفه يعني كل اللغه العربيه لا يمكن وصف
الشعور هذا ايييه شعور طبعا طيب
والاستقبال ما شاء الله الحمد لله شفت
الاهل وشفت الاصدقاء ومن عاشروني في
الاسير يعني كمان
كنت انا بالبيت عندهم وهو من بيت عنا
واحنا كمان تعلمنا سوا في نفس المدرسه
والاخره وتغربنا سوا وكمان رفاق نضال بدنا
نروح عند زميل او صديق مشترك وحسناتنا
انه يمكن نزور بيوت اسرع اخرين عن زورهم
ان شاء الله سوا
ماهر رساله للشعب الفلسطيني
التي تهتف باسمي فلسطين
عشرات الفلسطينيين اتو من القدس وام الفحم
وعكا والمدن المجاوره لتقديم التهاني
والتبريكات للاسير ماهر يونس على الرغم من
قرار وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اتمرن
كبير منع مظاهر الاحتفال ورفع الاعلام
الفلسطينيه احتفل عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين
بتحرير الاسير ماهر يونس والذي امضى
اربعين عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه لا
نكون غازي من قريه عراء العربيه
مش عايزين ختام التاسعه سيكون مع هذه
المشاهد من مباراه نجوم الهلال والنصر ضد
باريس سان جيرمان بقياده ميسي
والنصر طبعا والهلال بقياده رونالدو
والنتيجه تقدم الفريق الفرنسي حتى الان
بخمسه اهداف كما نتابع مقابل 3
[موسيقى]
كثير من المشجعين شوفهم يقوم بصور عديده
في في في ملعب الملك فهد واستمتعي بهذه
الاجواء تغيير ايضا
حماسيه
يعني كان هناك توافق كبير عليها من قبل
المشجعين السعوديين تقطي ضمن فعاليات
الرياض وضمن الرؤيه السعوديه لتعزيز حضور
المملكه رياضيا في المنطقه والعالم
[موسيقى]